Buonasera a tutti prima di iniziare a
raccontarvi la mia vertigine Vi chiedo
vi rubo soltanto un attimo e vi chiedo
di collaborare vi chiedo di chiudere gli
occhi e di tenere accesi tutti gli altri
sensi fatelo Però non pensate a me qui
sul palco non pensate al Ted fatelo
chiudete gli occhi Il vento vi Sforza il
volto ci siete voi soltanto voi non c'è
nulla intorno a voi non c'è nulla sotto
di voi magari lontananza riuscite a
scorgere persone case a sentire il
rumore delle delle macchine e poi c'è il
vostro corpo che lì la vostra casa ogni
giorno ogni secondo ma è instabile quel
corpo che è lo stesso di sempre di tutti
i giorni ma che sembra quasi anche se
perfettamente ancorato a terra sembra
quasi debba cadere da un momento
all'altro
adesso con i tempi che più ritenete
vostri Aprite gli occhi sono certa che
per chi lo ha fatto ha provato una
sensazione di instabilità
Ecco con poche parole qualche piccolo
frame ho voluto descrivere la sensazione
di vertigine quella vertigine che si
palesa generalmente quando ci si trova a
delle altezze molto elevate
precarietà paura di non percepirsi più
paura di perdere il controllo del
proprio corpo quel corpo che fino a
qualche minuto prima sembrava pronto lì
a rispondere a qualsiasi stimolo
la mia vertigine inizia durante l'età
adolescenziale quando a causa di una
cura farmacologica
il mio corpo ha subito un cambiamento
radicale un corpo in cui io non mi
riconoscevo più
a quell'epoca ora ne parlo con facilità
e ci rido anche su ma non è stato
semplice
a quell'epoca i social non c'erano ma i
canoni di bellezza erano ben noti dalla
TV in primis ai giornali ma io di quel
periodo soprattutto
dell'adolescenza Quando una donna una
ragazza diventa donna sboccia fiorisce
Io ricordo il peso del mio pareo quel
pareo da cui non mi staccavo mai per
andare al mare quel pareo con cui era
impensabile per me senza il quale era
impensabile per me raggiungere anche
solo la riva del mare era impensabile Sì
era roba per altre le altre che belle lo
erano davvero
in quel periodo di vertigine di
trambusto brillava la luce delle parole
di mio padre quando facevo dei paragoni
con le mie coetanee lui mi diceva sempre
ma figlia mia ma sei quelle belle Tu sei
una regina ovviamente sapevo che non era
così ma erano Balsamo quelle parole per
me così nutrendomi di quelle parole pian
piano Ho trovato il coraggio per
affrontare questa vertigine e fare un
grande salto ho deciso di rivolgermi ad
un dietologo all'epoca non esisteva la
figura del nutrizionista non era così
nota ricordo nitidamente la prima visita
Quando venne ad accogliermi
questo omone in camice bianco
palesemente in sovrappeso Volevo
scappare
non l'ho fatto gli ho dato fiducia ho
iniziato a seguire i suoi consigli quei
consigli che all'inizio per me andavano
bene ma ad un certo punto sentivo che
c'era qualcosa che non stava andando nel
verso giusto e così mi sono ascoltata e
questo perché la visita funzionava così
ci vedevamo alla prima visita e poi si
programmava il controllo dopo un mese un
mese e mezzo era la classica dieta da
software come la chiamo io una dieta che
mi lasciava lì
c'era c'erano i suoi consigli ma non
c'era lui mi sentivo consigliata ma non
accompagnata così
ad un certo punto ho deciso di fermarmi
e di ascoltarmi e di fare di testa mia
ho deciso di eliminare quegli alimenti
che per me in quel periodo della mia
vita non mi facevano stare bene
ho deciso di fare di testa mia
sbagliando quasi tutto dico quasi tutto
perché sicuramente non sbagliavo ad
ascoltarmi ma sbagliavo a far prendere
delle decisioni senza averne le basi
così pian piano ho deciso di iscrivermi
alla facoltà di biologia dell'Università
degli Studi di Milano e di proseguire
poi gli studi in nutrizione umana
nonostante avessi già un futuro
disegnato l'azienda di famiglia avrei
dovuto semplicemente chiedere le chiavi
dell'azienda a mia madre a mio padre ma
non l'ho fatto Mi sono ascoltata è vero
non ho fatto impresa ma oggi posso dire
di essere diventata l'imprenditrice di
me stessa
quando
è un paziente arriva in studio
In genere il problema principale non è
mai il
dimagrimento e chili di troppo i
centimetri di troppo le fantomatiche o
le fantomatiche intolleranze ci sono
altri problemi di fondo la pancia per
esempio avete mai provato ad ascoltare
la vostra pancia la pancia è piena di
vertigini la pancia può parlare della
vertigine dell'imbadenza spesso ci
troviamo a dover rispondere a delle
domande poste magari da persone che
della nostra vita non sanno nulla quando
ti sposi quando fai un figlio perché non
è un compagno perché una come te o uno
come te ancora non ha un compagno Beh
non è vero che si riesce andare oltre la
persona intelligente la persona educata
riesce ad andare oltre a guardare
dall'alto l'invadenza Non è vero per un
semplice motivo che la persona
intelligente educata è una persona anche
molto sensibile e che spesso diventa
vittima dell'invadenza la pancia può
parlare della solitudine ci si può
sentire soli di una grande città in un
piccolo paese in compagnia ci si può
sentire soli Quando ad un tratto
realizzi che non puoi più contare su
quelli che sono sempre stati i pilastri
della tua vita e tutto questo può
portare a rifugiarsi nel cibo a cercare
il cibo il comfort Food comfort Food
quel cibo che nutre quel cibo che
consola quel cibo che allevia sì perché
il cibo può diventare una coperta calda
durante una serata d'inverno quando
guardiamo la nostra
serie preferita quando
siamo Ci sentiamo soli o ancora di più
il cibo può diventare grembo materno un
grembo che nutre che accoglie che ci
coccola e che ci rassicura
ho deciso di iscrivermi alla facoltà di
di biologia di proseguire poi con
la specializzazione di scienze della
nutrizione umana e ho avuto anche la
fortuna di poter frequentare ed entrare
in quello che un po' il tempio della
della medicina a livello mondiale che
l'harvard Medical School dove
ho frequentato questi corsi di
nutrizione materno fetale e anche lì
sono arrivata e ho sbagliato Ho fallito
ho fallito perché pensavo di arrivare lì
e di imporre il modello della dieta
mediterranea sbagliando ad un certo
punto mi sono fermata anche lì E così
come mi ero ascoltata
ho capito che dovevo farlo anche con i
pazienti quei pazienti che soprattutto
dall'altra parte del mondo sono vittime
della cosiddetta transizione
nutrizionale gli africani che si
trasferiscono negli Stati Uniti o anche
qui i cinesi i nuovi ricchi come li
chiamano e così negli Stati Uniti
insieme al primario decisi di togliere
quel camice da omone e di mettere il
cappello da chef organizzando così delle
Cooking class in cui
ho praticamente
insegnato a queste donne a prendersi
cura del proprio corpo partendo
dall'alimentazione partendo dalla bici
fondamentalmente quindi riorganizzando i
passi dalle materie prime dalla
frequenza settimanale è stato un
percorso duro ma un percorso
gratificante che mi è servito per capire
che non dovevo imporre ma ascoltare
accompagnare ascoltare e accompagnare i
due punti forti della del mio metodo
Come funziona il mio metodo quando un
paziente arriva in studio
il generalmente ripeto ci sono delle
problematiche più importanti chili di
troppo non i chili di troppo i
centimetri di troppo non sono sono solo
la punta di un iceberg e faccio delle
domande delle domande magiche che io
chiamo che non svelerò che però portano
il paziente spesso a versare qualche
lacrima non li maltratto
ve lo garantisco ma sono delle domande
che smuovono scuotono vogliono
iniziare a sradicare con le cose che
sono lì ancorate da troppo tempo
Dopodiché quando mi rendo conto che il
problema non è
la bilancia chiamo in soccorso delle
figure in incognito con cui collaboro
che sono appunto Il sessuologo lo
psicologo il medico estetico
l'odontoiatra estetico sono tutte
persone con cui con cui collaboro
Dopodiché inizio a disegnare Il piano
alimentare come un abito sartoriale
customizzato Taylor Made entro nella
vita del paziente il paziente che viene
preso per mano e accompagnato in questo
percorso di rinascita non un percorso di
dimagrimento ma di rinascita
Dopodiché non esiste più che un paziente
mi dica dottoressa io non riesco a
seguire la dieta perché
sono tutto sono fuori tutte le sere a
cena dottoressa Sono dall'altra parte
del mondo non riesco ho paura di
vanificare i risultati dottoressa staro
via per tanto tempo come faccio allora
io gli dico guarda non c'è problema Ci
sono io il punto forte è proprio questo
del mio metodo e la presenza l'ascolto
Io sono partita proprio da da me stessa
dalla mia esperienza e sono avevo già
deciso di diventare la nutrizionista che
non ho mai trovato da quell'omone in
camicie bianco e poi tutto questo mi ha
portato a sviluppare questo metodo del
private la mia presenza la mia Costanza
il mio modo di esserci sempre accanto al
paziente e questo ha richiamato anche
l'attenzione di
giornali TV di radio e mi ha portato
anche a elaborare quella che
l'alimentazione per
i cantanti mi sono occupata di vocal
Fera al Festival di Sanremo per i vocal
coach gli speaker radiofonici e mi sono
occupata non solo poi di gestire
l'alimentazione ma anche di coordinare
di incastrarla nella vita nei tanti
impegni lavorativi
questo mi ha portato anche ad avere dei
pazienti molto esigenti da industriali
manager attori
personaggi che vivono
su jet privati piuttosto che
perennemente in vacanza pazienti molto
esigenti e mi ha portato sicuramente
a
sviluppare il metodo poi in modo diverso
questa mia conoscenza questa mia
Costanza ha fatto sì che diventassi
un'ancora per loro ovviamente se tutto
questo è accaduto lo devo anche al fatto
di aver ascoltato tante persone ho avuto
dei grandi esempi soprattutto di donne
che mi hanno dato forse il coraggio in
primis voglio ricordare mia nonna
Raffaella il più grande esempio di Forza
e coraggio che io abbia mai conosciuto e
poi ho avuto la grande fortuna di
incontrare dei
delle persone meravigliose durante il
mio percorso al liceo dei
compagni di viaggio che mi hanno
sostenuta che hanno mi hanno alleggerito
un po' il cuore in quel periodo in cui
io mi vedevo quasi un maschio e
soprattutto una persona a cui devo molto
che ha letto il mio disagio nei miei
occhi e con la sua discrezione con il
suo
il tuo insegnamenti mi ha dato forza e
coraggio la professoressa Vittoria leone
e poi anche le persone che hanno creduto
creduto in me a Milano la mia manager la
prima ad aver creduto in me che mi ha
detto Ylenia Guarda è arrivato il
momento di tirare di uscire dall'ombra
non puoi più stare dietro le quinte devi
far conoscere il tuo metodo perché in te
c'è l'elemento differenziante la tua
presenza la tua costanza
entrare nella vita dei dei tuoi pazienti
prenderli per mano e accompagnarli in un
percorso di rinascita e questo
l'elemento differenziante il private
nutritions nasce così
sicuramente devo lo devo a tante cose ma
lo devo soprattutto al fatto di aver
ascoltato me e tutte le mie vertigini
Grazie
[Applauso]